ça ne sera pas facile à compter de
demain et au cours des prochaines
semaines sur entre autres les ponts
reliant montréal et la rive sur le pont
mercier par exemple sera fermée en
direction sud
durant tout le long week-end de pâques
et sur champlain plusieurs fins de
semaine de travaux sont à venir récent
maisonneuve
les automobilistes devront s'armer de
patience il y aura sur les ponts reliant
montréal à la rive-sud encore plus de
travaux que l'an passé
on va doubler à l'intensité sur la
réfection de l'ensemble de notre réseau
sur le pont champlain
la super poutre sera retirée et
remplacée par une structure d'acier
il faut aussi refaire des joints de
dilatation et solidifier plusieurs
poutres premier blitz de travaux est
donc prévue en mai durant trois ou
quatre week-ends trois voies sur six
seront retranchés une seconde vague de
travaux aura lieu en septembre et
octobre
durant quatre ou cinq fins de semaine il
n'y aura qu'une voie ouverte dans chaque
direction
à cela s'ajoutent deux week-ends durant
lesquelles il n'y aura qu'une seule voie
sur le pont de l'île des soeurs
on va avoir une seule voie dans une
direction pendant le week-end et la même
chose un autre week-end que des taux va
se faire via bonaventure donc on peut
toujours se rendre mais savate impact
majeur sur la claque ainsi les travaux
majeurs risquent de sérieusement
compliqué la circulation certains
week-ends sur le pont champlain
dites-vous que l'été s'annonce encore
plus difficile pour ceux qui empruntent
quotidiennement le pont mercier où il
s'en va être un été chaud au pont
mercier 102 durant cette semaine de juin
là où il n'y aura qu'une voie ouverte
dans chaque direction sur le pont
mercier sur jacques cartier on prévoit
15 fermetures de nuit
chaque fois entre 1h et 4h du matin tous
ces chantiers coûteront 3 164 millions
de dollars
c'est deux fois plus qu'en 2013 ici
vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal